[Music]
you know the scene you know the story
for tim mcgraw and faith hill though it
was about way more than just playing
their parts their personal reaction to
what happens will blow you away
as the yellowstone universe continues to
expand the western drama's first
spin-off has wrapped its inaugural
season 1883 is a prequel to the
record-breaking series and chronicles
the dutton family's ancestors growling
journey from texas to montana before the
season came to an end it was announced
that more episodes would follow and fans
are already eager to see what comes
after the shocking finale episode 10
this is not your heaven sees the
dutton's eldest daughter elsa dutton
recovering from the arrow wound she
sustained in the previous episode many
1883 fans speculated that elsa would
survive the infection that began to set
in given that she is a main character
and the rapes are serious however the
finale proved this theory wrong despite
elsa's condition improving as a group
pushed forward on their long journey
things suddenly took a turn for the
worse drawing this is not your heaven
elsa must grapple with her doomed fate
and bid an emotional farewell to her
family by the end of the episode elsa
has succumbed to the infection declaring
she is unafraid before finally passing
away
that final father daughter scene was
clearly hard to watch for many and 1883
stars tim mcgraw and faith hill have
admitted that the entire episode was
difficult for them to shoot in an
interview with variety the real-life
couple opened up about the tragic death
of their on-screen daughter describing
the ark as one of the most incredible
stories she had ever read hill told the
publication as a mom i can't even allow
myself to go there i cannot it's really
hard even now to talk about because once
the tears start coming i can't stop them
i would tell the directors if we start
going it's going to be hard for me to
stop while james dutton gets to be with
elsa during her final moments margaret
must stay behind with her other children
watching helplessly as her daughter is
brought away to choose her final resting
place this scene in particular shook
hill during filming she told variety
imagine knowing that your child is going
to die and you cannot be by their side i
can't even imagine it ever i have not
recovered he went on to say that she
also cannot imagine how this loss will
affect james and margaret's marriage the
actress has been open about how 1883
takes an emotional toll on her noting
the death of her character's
sister-in-law earlier in the season
still makes her cry meanwhile tim mcgraw
told variety that when he read the last
scripts for season 1 of 1883 with hill
they couldn't stop crying he said
i mean ugly boo hoo crying i was a
blubbering idiot it was just so well
written so devastating and heartbreaking
but at the same time so on point and
poignant for what yellowstone turned out
to be mcgraw added it just gives you all
the reasons in the world where they
fight so hard for that land and why
their family fights so hard to keep what
they have it just made perfect sense no
matter how much sense it made though he
was still struck by elsa's death mcgraw
explained that he had to make an effort
not to get too emotional too early
during the scene but struggled because
isabelle may looks like she could be his
own daughter it's hard as a parent
playing that role you don't want to go
to any dark places in your mind about
your kid so you have to keep trying to
block that out and still be in the
moment with the character that you're
playing but the lines do get blurry
however he also agreed that this moment
played an important role in the greater
story even if fans aren't happy about it
mcgraw explained it's going to be a good
thing that they hate that ending because
it has to be that way and they know it
it's gonna be devastating why would you
watch stuff if it doesn't purge your
emotions
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]